support for big thing comes from
Microsoft delivering people ready
enterprise solutions designed to help
companies do more with less details at
microsoft.com / people ready
it's actually more possible to move
market share than it might be in a
normal environment and so being able to
have better awareness and being able to
more quickly respond competitively isn't
more importance
real time monitoring is a process by
which companies are building business
intelligence to understand in the way
that a National Intelligence Agency
would what is actually going on in the
ground on the ground in different parts
of the world in different parts of their
business that allows them to more
quickly respond to changes in the
external economic environment to
competitive moves to changes in the
financial markets to changes in prices
and reactions of different moves that
they're making so that they can have an
awareness of how each of those changes
may influence what their business
response should be and will quickly
adapt to them
even before the crisis the internet and
other related communications and
information technologies enabled a level
of transparency inside of institutions
not just businesses but government and
social sector institutions that was not
possible for before whether it's Yelp
for restaurants whether it's YouTube for
social movements whether it's the
ability to create a movement on the
internet that creates a new president
those are environments that would not
have been possible without the
ubiquitous pneus the capability and the
low cost of technology we've not yet
seen what that means for how companies
and large organizations actually operate
in that new environment it's going to
force a level of transparency it's going
to force a level of ability to respond
quickly to things that is going to
challenge many traditionally organized
institutions I think in the
intermediate-term that's actually going
to be good it creates a kind of
competitive pressure a kind of necessity
to deliver in the light of day that in
general will be good it will
particularly be challenging but in some
ways will be very good for the most
opaque institutions particularly in the
government creating visibility into how
money is spent creating visibility into
what the real returns on investment are
creating visibility into the actual
activities that occur and how well
they're done or not creating visibility
into how customers and taxpayers and
employees think about institutions is
challenging but it forces institutions
to be better and that's good for the
economy
it requires that the technology be
thoughtfully invested against processes
and activities that actually make a
difference for the organization and that
you adapt how you do business to reflect
that technology I think that's going to
be true in the next generation of web 20
technologies as well they can be
important enabler of allowing
particularly complex transactions and
interactions between individuals and
groups within a company and between
organizations to happen much more
effectively but they need to be done in
a way which are effectively implemented
and processes that are changed to take
advantage of that I personally find that
quite exciting and the opportunities for
knowledge sharing for real collaboration
for opening up ways to interact with
people halfway across the globe in a
real-time way interactively is just
quite exciting and for someone who spent
half their life on an airplane being
able to do that in videoconference
rather than getting on an airplane for a
one-hour meeting I find quite compelling
as well
I think the availability of some
technologies that allow for virtual
interaction whether it's really high
quality video conference or web presence
don't diminish the need for personal
interaction they just change the nature
of it and what it means is that you use
the time when you're together for the
kinds of social interactions and getting
to know people and really creating trust
and the relationships that then enable
you to apparate to operate effectively
virtually going forward it doesn't
diminish the importance of being
together it just changes the the purpose
of that and allows you to be more
effectively using your time in different
ways given the availability of personal
interaction and Technology intermediated
interactions in other settings support
for big thing comes from Microsoft
delivering people ready enterprise
solutions designed to help companies do
more with less details at microsoft.com
/ people ready